hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten wild heute gibt es wieder etwas
leckeres süßes und zwar einen süßen
nachtisch
ich glaube man spricht schoss aus und
zwar ist auf jeden fall so ein brandtag
gebäck dass wir dann frittiert in der
pfanne oder im topf besser gesagt in
fett
da kommt das später zum zubau oben drauf
und dann kann man das ganze noch tanken
etwas schoko schokosoße genau das wollte
ich sehr spät dann zukunft ganz genau
das ist ja richtig was für die figur und
ich will sagen ich zeige euch einfach
mal kurz die zutaten für den brand teig
das ist übrigens ein ganz normaler
standard brandtag aus dem kann man auch
windbeutel machen und klein ich hab's
nicht vergessen ich werde auch in
zukunft demnächst irgendwann windbeutel
machen also für den teig brauchen wir
250 milliliter wasser 60 gramm butter
eine prise salz 200 gramm und drei bis
vier eier da kommt einfach darauf an wie
groß die sind und zuerst müsst ihr jetzt
das wasser in den topf geben
dann kommt da die butter dazu und es
lassen wir einfach mal ganz kurz
aufkochen
jetzt kocht hier die mischung jetzt
kommt hier die prise salz mit dazu woran
ist gerade eine karte einfach so mann
hinter der kamera eckert und solange das
70 hier kocht muss sich jetzt das mehl
auf ein sprung mit dazugeben und dann
ganz lange ruhe
jetzt habe ich das so lange gerührt ist
das ganze nur noch ein kloß ist und man
sieht es jetzt auch hier unten am
topfboden das ist jetzt ziemlich weiß
also es hat einen weißen belag und das
heißt jetzt einfach dass mädels
abgebrannt deswegen heißt dieser tag
auch updike
das macht man einfach dass es nicht so
nach mehr schmeckt sondern eben
ich würde mich beeilen wer sind scheiße
angewandt seither ist sie nicht
anstrengend weil ich noch dazu sagen ja
morath jetzt vorhandene zuschauer
geschrieben lasse durch eigene zukunft
deponieren wird werden auf 200 videos
immer noch nicht zugenommen
der bund nehme ich bitte wieder und
jetzt fühle ich mir den teig um damit
ich einfach nicht arbeiten kann und
damit der teig so ein bisschen abkühlen
und den topf krieg später wieder sauber
indem ich einfach so wasser rein gibt es
kurz aufkochen lassen und dann dürfte er
wieder sauber sein
jetzt verteile ich den hier so bisserl
dass er einfach bisserl abkühlt denn ich
muss er gleich noch die eier dazugeben
um ich die halt jetzt mit dazu gibt dann
gewinnen die dann hat früher ein
jetzt sehen wir eine zwangs frage und
zwar mit zwangs frage aber ich habe das
schon vor dem brief gefragt wie sie
eingerichteten komm ich fragte mich noch
mal im video
da bin ich den zuschauern erklären kann
ich wurde gezwungen diese fragen zu
stellen
sally wie bist du auch dieses rezept
bekommt eine kleine zweimal erstehen und
dann auch meinen zuschauern also das
rezept oder besser zeigt das foto habe
ich auf instagram und dann habe ich
gleich so stoppt das gebäck kriegt und
man hat sieht ja eigentlich so dass es
halt brand eike becker schaut euch
fußballwelt wie es heißt und deswegen
musste ich stelle jetzt ein brand her
und frittiert ist und macht es eben so
und dann habe ich eben recherchiert und
herausgefunden dass heißt schulbus nur
weiß ich jetzt hat er das ausspricht nur
atemlos
so ist es halt auch spanisch ist
eigentlich aber ich meine überall der
brandheide beck bei den türken gibt es
auch da wird so hat in zimt zucker
gewälzt sondern kommt dann halt in so
mit zuckersirup da heißt es um
attraktive cash vielleicht aber
thematisch ja das weg aber ich glaub
haushalt aber ihr könnt mir gern muss
hacke wie das heißt dampf zum teil kann
es sein
die roten brunnen auge angebrannt etwas
anderes das ist abgekühlt als ich habe
bis zu 23 minuten lang jetzt gemacht und
jetzt als erster ritter zu 240 an der
hypo und jetzt versuche ich das hier ein
und zuerst könnte man jetzt meine das
verbindet sich nicht aber ihr müsst
einfach immer weiter gehen immer weitere
und dann verbindet sich das gleich das
kommt mir spanisch vor
kannste wortspiele hier machen dass ist
gekürt
zum beispiel und handgerät mit knethaken
hat kann das auch so machen aber ich
habe gern zurück gerät wenn sich das
verbunden hat gebe ich das zweite eigene
dazu mache ich das gleiche wieder und
dann erst das dritte
und dann entscheide ich ob ich überhaupt
noch einen drauf oder auch eben dazu
geben
mein tag ist jetzt fertig und muss sagen
schoppel muskelarbeit wenn man das so
per hand macht arbeitest du so ein
richtig schöner festtag glänzender teig
und den werde ich jetzt gleich mit dem
spritzbeutel ins fett gießen oder
spritzen
deswegen habe ich jetzt hier so eine
einwegspritze beutel und gibt da meinen
adapter rein was für alle die das jetzt
noch nicht wussten wie dem spritzbeutel
da kann ich das hier aufschneiden um
durch schieben dann kommt eine stern
spiele drauf die hat jetzt neun
millimeter und dann der deckel vom
adapter und dann könnten wir über dem
spritzbeutel stände stülpen und einfach
rein und deswegen ist auch ganz gut dass
hier zum sprit weil die stände haben
oder ihr nehmt einfach ein hohes gefäß
und stellt es darüber und wer jetzt aber
keinen spritzbeutel hat mit télécom
gefrierbeutel nehme und das ganze ohne
schüler benutzen metall dann nicht so
schön aber schmeckt wahrscheinlich
gleich
unterstützt mich so arg viel teig
deswegen kann ich als alles auf einmal
rein geben
die rechte hat sich jetzt noch kurz aus
und lassen in der zwischenzeit schon mal
meinen fed heiß werden und sobald es
dann auf 170 grad erhitzt ist ich
benutzt vergleichen thermometer aber ich
zeige mich auch gleich wie es mit einem
holzstäbchen geht dann zeige ich euch
einfach gleich es weitergeht meinte
jetzt heiß und ich hab das jetzt mit
thermometer abgemessen schützen bisschen
heißer als 170 grad also erst 1890
aber ich habe auch in der mitte gemessen
und jetzt kann ich euch das nur mit dem
holzstäbchen zeigen
ich habe kein holz kochen werkzeug mir
also normalerweise machen das einfach im
kopf kochlöffel holzlöffel so heißt es
und ich nenne es jetzt einfach mit einem
schaschlikspieß und michael frein halte
und dann bilden sich dass die flächen
drumherum
das heißt dass fetish heiß genug jetzt
braucht ihr neben dem spritzbeutel auch
noch eine schere
denn ich werde jetzt hier ganz lange
streifen spritzen einfach direkt ins
heiße fett
ich wollte gerade streifen und den
schneide jetzt hier vorne einmal ab was
macht jetzt auch nichts machen
gewissenlos stücke und das mache ich
jetzt hier einfach so weiter müsste halt
echt langsam spritzen
die
dann lassen wir einfach von beiden
seiten so ein bisschen anbraten bis sie
goldbraun sind und ich habe mir hier
schon nebendran ein blech zurechtgelegt
mit etwas küchenkrepp drin
einfach zum abtropfen und gleich brauche
ich dann hier noch etwas zimt und etwas
zucker da könnt ihr so viel nehmen wie
ihr wollt denn darin werde ich sie dann
gleich wenden
und während die hier jetzt noch
auspacken zeige ich nur eine zweite
möglichkeit und zwar wenn es vielleicht
sagt ich möchte es nicht verziehen wenn
es nicht zu fettig da kann es auch im
backofen machen
da werden sie dann zwar nicht so ganz
knusprig aber sie schmecken auch gut und
wenn man dann später einfach den
geschmackstest und dafür spritze ich die
mir jetzt hier auf ein backblech mit
backpapier
und damit die aber nicht zu trocken
werden und trotzdem schön goldbraun
werden besprüht jetzt noch mit bakterien
spray das ist nur pflanzenfett oder ihr
nehmt einfach olivenöl nicht olivenöl
sonnenblumenöl und bestreicht es mit
einem pinsel und dann gebe ich die bei
190 grad für etwa 10 bis 15 minuten in
den backofen einfach bitteschön gold
frauen sind und dann gucken wir uns
einfach gleich an wenn sie besser
schmecken
jetzt kann ich sie herausnehmen und
abtropfen lassen und gibt dann gleich
die nächsten meter zu
während die jetzt noch auspacken werde
ich schon mal alles andere zu bereiten
und vorbereiten und zwar nehme ich jetzt
einfach meinen zucker dessen jetzt bei
mir so zwischen 50 und 100 gramm und
gibt da zimt mit dazu dann nehmt ihr
euch einfach so viel wie ihr möchtet
also ich mag es gern mit viel fisch
deswegen habe ich jetzt hier fast ein
esslöffel sind mit drin und verrührt es
jetzt kurz und man erkennt sie auch an
der farbe ob jetzt genug sind mit drin
ist oder nicht
das benutze ich gleich um sie damit ein
bisschen zu bestreuen
es ist zwar ein bisschen viel zucker
aber chips dann einfach auf und
benutzten irgendwann mitarbeiter und in
der zwischenzeit mache ich auch schon
mal meine schokosoße und dafür habe ich
hier schon mal 100 gramm sahne also
schlagsahne und 50 gramm
vollmilchschokolade und jetzt muss ich
einfach nur kurz meine sahne aufkochen
und sobald die sahne aufgekocht ist
kommt jetzt noch die schokolade mit dazu
und jetzt berühre ich das so lange bis
sich die show raw klümpchen eben
aufgelöst haben
und dann habe ich schon meine fertige
show passt einfach
übrigens müsst ihr beim spritzbeutel
aufpassen dass ihr da nicht zu viel
druck ausübt weil es ansonsten echt sein
kann dass er platz weil dieser brandtag
sehr fest ist oder ihr nehmt einfach
direkt einen spritzbeutel der eben nicht
so ein einweg spritzbeutel ist sondern
schon stoff spritzbeutel den hab ich
auch da habe ich wollte einfach dass sie
das innen drin dafür drin steckt aber
ich muss echt aufpassen
auch wenn es wieder rund
m
so ich bin jetzt fertig mit dem
auspacken und wir haben bereits
beschlossen was will die fed variante
besser finden weil muss hier ganz
deutlich
also das sind jetzt die aus dem backofen
diesem schönen gerade aus aber der
nachteil ich einfach keinen zucker dran
aus dem tales und bisschen dran aber
zucker hinter keiner dran
deshalb müsste die dann so ein bisschen
in zucker tippen aber ich glaube wenn
man so was macht dann frittierten auf
einfach ein bisschen und fertig sowas
macht man ja nicht jeden tag
ich finde jetzt hier meine schokosoße in
kleinen schälchen um übrigens mit ich
persönlich mehr zur zar peter tendieren
einfach weil es ein schokoladiger
schmeckt und dunkler ist aber ich hab's
de moura zu lieb so gemacht weil er hat
gern vollmilchschokolade und mein
übliches fed das werde ich es bestimmt
gefragt was ich damit machen und zwar
hatte ich hier frittierfett genommen ich
habe mal den deckel drauf einfach damit
kein wasser und nichts drankommt müsste
auch recht vorsichtig sein mit fett und
ich kann das jetzt sogar noch ein
zweites oder drittes mal benutzen weil
es eben frittierfett ist und ich kann es
eben mehrmals erhitzen
wenn ihr jetzt normale sonnenblumenöl
genommen habt müsste das ist einfach
abkühlen lassen könnte es dann zum
beispiel in einem plastikbeutel füllen
und dann eben im restmüll entsorgen oder
zu seiner abfallsammelstellen bei euch
im ort geben also das könnte beides
machen
so und jetzt kann man gerne probieren
karima ich glaube weil der moral ist gar
nicht da ist kein student mit probieren
übrigens herzlich bestimmt aufgefallen
ein schildchen soll ich die fettfreie
variante nehmen oder als ob zucker im
südlichen gebiet während der show
russischen nochmal wetter kennt man auch
zum beispiel im april mussten hat nach
hatten aus waltroper oder marmelade oder
einfach sahne dazu so steif geschlagen
es war auch lecker ich wurde also wenn
wir dann damit fertig sind würde ich
sagen die man bei dem schönen wetter
noch eine runde laufen und macht auf
jeden fall
und ihr könnt euch gern das rezept auf
cds - blog.de abschauen ausdrucken
nachmachen genießen und mir dann noch
das boot oder fortschicken form genießen
genau und wir sehen uns sondern nächsten
mal wieder es war
bei kunst zu machen dabei noch gut
auszusehen mein name auf hold herab